hallo mein name ist luca und herzlich
willkommen zu minecraft in brutal des
spiels kritiker lenny levy mit der
linken aus schieße ich mit der rechten
mausklick einfach mal space um das ganze
hier ach du heilige scheiße ich möchte
euch übrigens bitten dass jedes video
wirklich bis zu ende an schaut weil ich
am ende noch eine ganz ganz ganz ganz
wichtige sache sagen muss bezüglich
minecraft das ist keine ironie das ist
wirklich unglaublich wichtig ich glaube
ihr wisst mittlerweile was sich
meinte mit minecraft in butter das ganze
spiel hat mich so ein bisschen an wie
hieß noch mal dieses spiel fürs iphone
wo man auch so oben laufen konnte und
alle abknallen konnte das spiel hatte
auch seine blöcke ähnliche grafik und
ich weiß nicht mehr wie heißt aber
dieses macht denn hier gerade für ein
blutbad 70 kills
ich versuche diesmal einfach mal so ein
bisschen mehr an bewegung zu bleiben
damit das ganze hier nicht direkt wieder
aus dem ruder läuft dafür dass es
wirklich so ein onlinespiel es ist es
ultras ge macht es heißt critical nhl
ation falls du das auch spielen wollt
das ist echt und dran also mit der
grafik dass die oben wirklich so ein
bisschen verschwommen ist und hier mehr
so gerade und dann auch mit dem man dann
was ist ja nicht hier kann er nicht
unter par zu 130 ready das heißt wenn
ich jetzt die eindrücke wo ist die acea
30 sitzt denn dass sie vorne für einen
raum i
das war gerade blutbad 102 ps
schon mal ein bisschen besser das ganze
ist einfach so ein zombie survival und
ich muss irgendwie überleben kann ich
einen baum komplett verschicken so dass
er irgendwie umfeld oder so yahoo ist
umgefallen bruder hier und warm und warm
und ich bin tot
ich sollte nicht so auf diese riesigen
explosion machen schaut man wenig space
druck gehypten die alle 40
wenn ich hier mit köpfen alle 40
hahaha ich muss einfach die ganze zeit
in bewegung bleiben und versuchen die
schüsse von denen nicht auf mich drauf
keiner mein gott ich hab schon wieder
leben verloren
junge und ihr da hinten war hier noch
ein und da noch ein und da auch noch ein
und dann heute noch einen und da auch
und ihr könnt hier so aber ich versuche
mal einfach wieder zu diesem gebäude da
hinten zu kommen ohne auf dem weg zu
sterben weil ich wusste jetzt noch gar
nicht was das konnte ich darin machen
für das gebäude ist hier nicht mehr groß
ist okay hier ist es gebäude was das ist
es ist weg ich weiß nicht ob das spiel
gerade spaß macht für euch zuzuschauen
wenn ich es locker aber zum zocken macht
es definitiv spaß ich bin ja immer so
ein bisschen anfällig für diese
minimalistische grafik und dies hier
perfekt also dies mit dem schnee und es
macht spaß ich frag mich nur das alles
ist gibt es noch eine andere map oder
mehr waffen des guides ist ja immer noch
diese heftige dings hier wo ich die
ganze zeit überlegt ich hatte mich
selbst geschossen ich wollte aber
eigentlich auch noch über ein thema
reden wo es um minecraft geht und zwar
komme ich nicht mehr in minecraft ich
war ja bis gestern im urlaub also ich
nehme die produziert wieder vor weil ich
über silvester zu hause im niederfeld
bin auf einer party blabla ich war eine
woche in österreich im urlaub und da
habe ich eine mail bekommen und von
einem zuschauer der majolika ich wollte
dir nur sagen dass du deinen minecraft
namen zu größte ring geändert hast nein
habe ich nicht ich habe mir dabei
erstmal nichts gedacht und dachte mir
nur was labert er ich habe meinen namen
locker mein gott das musste ich grad
machen
ich habe nur gedacht du ja ich habe
meinen namen nicht geändert wie so
schreibt er mir das brauche ich
eigentlich nicht darauf eingehen so und
dann hat wollte ich mich jetzt wirklich
gerade in minecraft einloggen
habe ich gewonnen eigentlich hier gerade
dann wollte ich mich halt heute in
minecraft einloggen und habe dann einen
baum mein gott ich bin total wollte ich
mich heute mit contractor so in
minecraft einloggen und dann kommt auf
einmal so jedes existiert nicht dann
habe ich über die email probiert oder
steht er die e-mail existiert nicht dann
habe ich tatsächlich mal probiert den
namen größte ring doch ein zu geben hat
auch nicht funktioniert
ich weiß nicht was ich machen soll es
geht nicht darum dass ich zu geizig bin
irgendwie nochmal 20 dollar oder so für
minecraft auszugeben sondern einfach um
diesen namen crafter den möchte ich gern
behalten ich weiß auch ehrlich gesagt
nicht ob es richtig ist dass ich das
ganze zu einem video anspreche weil es
kann ja sein dass das irgendjemand sieht
und sich dann denkt der name kontrakt
als frei oder oder halt nicht oder kann
ich habe keine ahnung von und vielleicht
kann ihnen jetzt irgendjemand nehmen
keine ahnung ist ein bisschen blöd
gerade mir ist es halt heute aufgefallen
weil ich vor produziere und ich wollte
das video vom freitag drehen minecraft
video wo ich eine mod vorstelle und dann
sehe ich auf einmal kommen nicht
einloggen deswegen wollte ich euch jetzt
fragen was soll ich da jetzt machen muss
ich mir minecraft neukauf was ist das da
vorne überhaupt hierfür ein fucking habe
ich jetzt das hier irgendwie zerstört
habe ich jetzt deren quelle kaputt
gemacht oder was habe ich jetzt getan
jedenfalls habe ich alles mögliche
probiert doch auf der website nicht
wieder einzuloggen und alles mögliche
gemacht deswegen ich wollte euch jetzt
nur kurz fragen ob er eventuell wisst
wie ich da meinen namen zurück kriegen
könnte oder ob es überhaupt möglich ist
oder woran es liegen könnte mir wörter
geschrieben ab dem ersten zweiten kann
man sich jetzt irgendwie kontrast wenn
man minecraft und das möchte ich halt
ungern ist ich möchte aber gerne
behalten das heißt wenn ihr irgendwelche
ideen ab schreibt das scannen und in die
kommentare ich beende jetzt an dieser
stelle auch das video hier weil ich
jetzt ein friseurtermin abal die haare
wirklich also das ist nicht mehr normal
was ist die cloud zu mittlerweile seine
ideen habe wie ich minecraft
zurückbekomme oder spielen kann dann
schreibt sie mir gerne in die kommentare
das video wenns euch